welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a friend
got a terrific uh podcast for you this
fine day but of course people can listen
to it whenever they like it's not like
traditional broadcasting where this is
the show for today you could be hearing
this many years from now after I've
committed horrific crimes unless they're
listening on satellite radio then they
have no choice yes then they're hearing
me pre-horrific crimes oh yeah you can
only imagine what I'm up to you're just
planning it right now you're in the
planning stuff I'm not a good planner
I'd be a terrible planner as a as a
criminal really I think yeah I would if
you think I'd be one of those criminals
who was the standard thing where you
spend months casing the bank and you get
all the blueprints I wouldn't do any of
that no I just go in wing it you
wouldn't have your assistant sewn a plan
for you well I'd ask her to and then
what would happen Sona I probably would
get distracted and then the day of you'd
be like where are the plans and I'd be
like I don't I don't have them I don't
have them uh yeah I I got busy can I rob
the bank with I've always wanted to Rob
well you you know we discussed this a
million times you uh have stolen in the
past and you probably steal again
um no I'm not I'm done my stealing days
are behind me except you want to rob a
bank yeah but now you're saying you'd
like to rob a bank I want in on this
don't you guys kind of want to Rob or
not even a bank but like it's kind of
fun to just take something oh yeah like
from an old person who can't stop you oh
wait I think I went the wrong way well
so I'm sorry it's so much easier than a
bank an old lady with a big purse just
grab it it's my purse that has my social
security money yeah what are you gonna
do about it
God's uh I want to just quickly say that
that's a terrible accident it is that's
not cool at all well depends on how much
money is in the purse if we were to rob
a bank what would our mask theme be you
know how they're like in Point Break
they have the ex-president presidents
yeah and the Supreme Court Justice oh
okay so who are a current Supreme Court
Supreme Court Justices so who are we I
call Sonia but you kind of look like her
you've seen other hair so people are
gonna know it's you yeah the name is so
similar I'll be a Elena no I think I
think you're clearance time you're
Clarence Thomas [ __ ] no [ __ ] you too no
but wait a minute absolutely
why can't I be that you give me Clarence
Thomas yep no
no book do you want to get caught
no
cool one oh
cool he likes rving okay yeah I heard he
likes to drive around in his RV it's
pretty cool and I'll take a cool one it
can be Alito yeah you're a leader you're
very nice you're Rock you're brittle
you're very rigid when it comes to uh
constitutional uh law I'm going to Oh no
you're Kavanaugh
Kavanaugh came in with a lot of really
dark frizzy hair
and uh it seemed a little high
that's on point and was waving a gun
around he came in Kavanaugh came in with
Sotomayor and a very tall Sotomayor yeah
a six foot four Sotomayor with a shock
of red hair coming out from behind you
guys make me Kavanaugh I'm going to
sabotage this baby listen I like you as
uh like we said I think you're a strict
yeah constructionalist or is it
constructionist I'm sorry oh
apologies we gotta get this straight
yeah it's fine if you don't be Kavanaugh
you can be Thomas that's okay yeah okay
you guys I don't want to do this I don't
want to rob a bank with you too what I
don't want to rob a you two would be the
worst to rob a bank with too excuse me I
don't know you'd be like excuse me is it
okay will you Robbie is that because I
just said excuse me
you're too polite I can't see you guys
it's good to ask permission beforehand
yeah I think it would also be a problem
that I would want
um
some credit for having done it so I'd
probably take the mask off at some point
get a plug-in for the podcast oh no take
a couple of selfies with people and what
are our roles who's driving getaway
who's safe cracker who's leader I'm
gonna say Sono would be a great getaway
driver because you are fast yeah and
Reckless and you just go For Broke yeah
and your cars often aren't like they're
of course that we can just scrub you
know we can just set them on fire and
walk away and it's not a huge loss you
know what I mean it's just like someone
will meet up Jetta and then yeah
whatever you torch it and you move on I
drive a minivan now so oh I didn't I
haven't seen them anymore oh my gosh
it's a whole new world okay so we're all
dressed as uh various controversial
Supreme Court Justices and we're robbing
a bank in a minivan yeah and I can't
take I don't want to take the car seats
out so you guys have to be in the back
third no no I'm sitting in like Mikey's
car seat yeah you guys go rushing in and
you're in Charlie's and and Sony goes
she pulls up she rushes in to rob the
bank and you and I can't unstrap
ourselves so our legs are kicking wildly
as Supreme Court Justices ladies Supreme
Court Justices we hear the alarm go off
Sona comes running out with the cash
we're still wiggling just eating rice
puffs we're eating rice puffs and
throwing the crumbs around juice boxes
and why do you guys for reasons to be
for reasons I don't understand I [ __ ]
myself
and not even out of fear I just because
I just was like three o'clock it's time
Blart
and then you have to get in the car and
suddenly
forget that we're not Mikey and Charlie
and you start yelling at us yeah and we
scream until you put on a DVD of Moana
yeah wait so I just robbed the bank
myself yeah you two are yeah but then
later on when we're dividing up the
money we insist that we each get our
third and we're real like what are you
we're all in this together you guys you
never got out of your baby seats Conan
you pooped yourself and then I had to
play a Moana CD while you guys ate rice
puffs
and you yeah we want our money
oh even split
yeah in this together or we're not